[Music]  hello planet earth I'm Eva Tyson and  joining me up is one of my colleagues  dr. grant moon hi soup is here to  analyze a very special wave of radiation  but what makes this radiation so special  is that it has no discernible source  [Music]  location unknown  this planet is almost 800 thousand  light-years from Earth we're in the  middle of the most fascinating  scientific opportunity in history are  you seeing this it's alien long do you  think it's been here a lot longer than  us which could mean one of two things  either whatever was on it is dead by now  or what they've had time to breathe  we don't get out of here it doesn't  matter how interesting this place is no  one will ever know maybe birth isn't  human we are not staying here  survivors keep moving I'm going to get  us the hell out of here  I've been waiting for you a long time  you know who I am ps4 for the players